you to say what it needs to sing right
receiving content and I believe we are
live welcome to the I lords podcast and
the Lords of gaming dotnet episode
number 124 and it's another glorious
Sunday we're back at the roundtable on
the Lord's Day I'm very excited about a
special guest and we've got Kingdom Come
deliverance announcements iron harvest
news gears 5 impressions projects X
cloud in Korea and Nintendo Direct to
discuss so we gonna get right into it I
want to introduce the Lord who the ILP
first got the opportunity to be in the
flesh at e3 2018 this Lord's passion for
his craft technical acumen and game
promotion skillset aren't truly a sight
to behold
and is the epitome of a cult classic
underdog rising into one of gaming's
most successful stories of 2019
introducing the PR manager for warhorse
studios and voice actor for the
critically acclaimed Kingdom Come
delivering franchise most recently
recently designated the Lord of iron
harvest and who studio by far holds the
title for the best USB press kit in the
game live from the Czech Republic by way
of Germany and making his debut into the
realm of the Lords mommy Lord to buy his
stall swilling how you doing sir Wow
even set my full name thank you Lord for
the invitation it's an honor
I came with weapons just to be sure I'm
a big main weapon just in case guys
thought I'm prepared oh he is ready in
the robe he's got the weapon of choice
got the mace where's your sword man he's
got it here's Henry sword Wow
and I even have absolute I'm
well-prepared gentlemen yes you are
well-prepared scallops is safe I feel
good about Scotty
this concert is safe now Oh absolute
pleasure to have you in bed your Lord at
what you do long overdue
you don't mean actually we've met you
two actually a good friend Lord wreck
but um yeah fresh off is calm man no
it's been a real busy time for you and
but otherwise yes yes definitely
Gamescom is by far for me the most
interesting and important event not only
because I'm German and it well the
studio my kingdom come determines
Studios in Prague so it's way closer to
the German audience which makes it
easier for us promoted though the event
generally is way bigger games become
compared to in 3 or packs or whatever
and the big advantage is that it's a
consumer event what I mean is that the
daily ticket costs like 10 bucks or
something Wow
yeah and III I think it's the weekend
tickets like 300 or so and you cannot
remember so all in all you're much
closer to the people which means a lot
of handshaking selfies which is cool I
really and for me as a PR guy media
presentations and I had this year for
iron harvest because Cassidy has nothing
to show now but Eirene harvest I had 290
appointments 219 unique media so they
had several poppers sometimes but 290
unique media every 30 minutes I had four
new guys and then you have to do like
the same show over and over and over
again what rumors I saw the trailer 10
times a day
you are obese just to see you work even
at e3 and in the scrambling the
commitments and you're like a machine
and then he's doing everything that he's
like playing the game he's speaking the
audio guys speaking of it like you or I
think Toby yes good okay so Thank You
Toby does dev I do your might get mine
yeah man we're just looking at you
moving around and I was just like wow I
don't know how you do it don't be like
you are moving at a hundred miles an
hour you know you know it's funny I
never really eat for example on events
I'm always so in tune well in the USA
especially I get the full-fledged
American breakfast of course okay of
course thank you can pancakes year a
week a year it's in LA and I eat all the
trash but it's really good any event and
I don't know why I'm so in my tunnel so
on adrenaline or whatever that I when
the bell rings and the event is over the
day like and people are like always
starving we have to eat some things like
hmm I don't know I don't know I'm not
really hungry and 30 minutes later I kid
you notice I feel like I'm dying we have
like like maybe 50 meters red you had no
no you know what it is when we saw him
his energy level is so high that
adrenaline is pumping so much that you
can see it but is a love for whatever
you're doing and that pushes you through
the day so you know yeah you see the the
the trail of ten times a day but ten
times a day is still fresh you don't
come off tie it at the 10th time you're
coming off as fresh is the first time
and they really come across and it's
really amazing
I'm breathtaking it's amazing but I'll
give them credit to is like um even if
like one of the testers is playing and
they get stuck like Toby in the middle
of presentation will grab the controller
and get through he's an expert at the
game it
well off-camera I told you that now that
I'm shifting projects that you know deep
Silva bought warhorse to do so I'm
technically we are a studio from deep
server now and I should do another
project which has nothing to do at all
with with wall studios I am in a way in
a triangle between the new project the
old project and deep Silva who's the
mothership right now and what what you
were talking about or it's very nice
thank you
oh you have nice words for me is the
something deep Civic or street
credibility yes yes your controller cred
is this [ __ ] you get busy with the most
community PR managers could be they
can't do that at the same time while
showcasing okay that is an art no I like
we need to sovereign Issei okay so we're
gonna walk through this area don't go
there don't go there with a woman
listen yeah but you know we got the Four
Horsemen of gaming those original Lords
of the realm here at the round table
my co-host with the coal most my brother
from another mother the difficult game
khakhra and the howl of the young wolf
mommy
Lord addict are you doing sir I'm tired
we might have to renegotiate these
contracts next year this it's only for a
few weeks the Lords must bid football
new son or few weeks few is a few like
for it's probably it's probably gonna be
half of that before people even realize
we go in at 11 a.m.
27 people realized what's going down the
real mess up the Jews are waking up
later like what the ghost is supreme
chief Harvey a lot of people to chat but
an attic man what's been going on I know
there's a certain game you've probably
been playing Oh what came with that
possibly you talk about that Final
Fantasy a kingdom comes in a month ago
well don't don't don't worry about that
I'm gonna get you that yo we got your
name oh yeah this week addict well uh
gears v came out mm-hmm
and then 24 hours later Xbox Live goes
down with kids food trying to beat this
game we got to the last act then I
started heading go back to work so I'm
sitting there waiting I'm all right when
I get back
it was right when because we gotta do
two days early so when the game came out
I was four game Pass ultimate users I
was alright so let's go ahead and finish
this game so I can get the review out
there get their gears fives not working
go figure
because there's just so much traffic
here's five servers can handle this I
was like I was like kid let's just do it
tomorrow
I'm over it I wasn't over it at the time
I'm over it now we'll play this tomorrow
happy I get home the never go beat this
game and it i'ma tell you right now I
know who did it
oh stop listen here Jade oh I knew you
knew that hug
was coming out god of war was in
jeopardy he was like you know what we go
shut this down I was mad as hell took I
think I beat it in twenty five hours
like I beat the game in like 17 but I've
been playing you know multiplayer -
horde and you know that took a lot of
that it's been taking the majority of my
week I've been playing Final Fantasy 8 I
haven't played it a whole lot because
I've been busy at work but it's been a
crazy week for games yeah it's been has
been pretty intense man that's what's up
I see one of our Lord's is a little
dance I don't know if I could do his
intro right now straight but if he
returns but I guess we still have
everyone knows the Incredible Hulk of
this aka the XS gamer whoo the Lord of
combat sports king of the statutes who
demands nothing less than that premium
experience and is the leader of the
fraud alert movement ooh
beloved Lord King how you doing sir
oh my god macho man's in the building
[Music]
yes he did King gives it within the
wizard gives it whatever shoutout to the
logo supreme the right-hand man of the
Kings alone he out here very early
that's my that's my guy right there oh
let me see Oh y'all see Hawkeye right
gotta load the game of down next to you
I could see exactly why this man is
overlooked and disrespected a very good
statue is fantastic as you can see it's
pending in the background is way bigger
than what y'all think and there's way
more intricate when you get a chance to
see the pictures and read the article
that myself and look
we'll work very hard on please just give
it a check let me tell you something
about my man Kebede oh yeah yeah this
level of dominance see and now see we
grew up in infancy of the UFC
when hoist Gracie had his level of
dominance and the the balance and the
UFC wasn't like solidified yet it was
still gained and may footing now UFC has
made it to a point where it's an
established force and now you're looking
for their Muhammad Ali you're looking
for their Floyd you're looking for their
Mike Tyson's and khabib is such a talent
yes and such he's hard to quantify
because you know why his talent
outshines his persona because his
persona is very humble very
family-oriented very solid family base
and his his his skill level outshines
that and the fact that he doesn't speak
English as much you know in UFC is
predominantly you know English type of
speaking because the places they go -
they were in Dubai Saudi Arabia yeah and
let me tell you something that man put
on such a show such a technical force if
you're a fan or not of the UFC you got
to respect his greatness and I can now
wait to see somebody even push him
because he's not be important at being
push he's on another level
yes not an eruption King I want to shout
to us we have a super chat shot to couch
gaming in the city with the file a super
chat listen to that Troy segment from
Lord King last week five times had me
dying kings of gravity salute gave me I
love it the king o nlg my boy energy
stingers in the buildin sheets are
wicked good gamers in the building
we got our PAX East brothers nice loud
with your anchorman it's really nice out
here everybody's adjusted to the time
king it's early in the morning
these are the early folk you know we're
still talking work 11:00 a.m. right let
me see what I played this weekend game
Pass
other than that super spectacular
captain game pass game let me tell you I
played blazing chrome and Lord sovereign
and I got a chance to you know do the
interview with the developers Louise at
our packs and the game is a throwback to
contra and it plays just like his
playing offered a Genesis - any frame
dip of any any hiccups the game is
phenomenal a lot of times you know we
overlook games inside game pass I
suggest everybody get a chance try to do
- one game a week a new game try
something new try to test it out
something that you wouldn't have paid
any money for you know to buy or see
then test it out and I'm I'm pretty sure
you're gonna be pleasantly surprised
with all they have to offer because too
many people say there's no games out
here it is a ton of game we got totally
I kingdom come delivers a game yes did
you just say one game week oh my god I
wish I have so much time yet like you
know token that's one game to try okay
define try then I don't do you know do
you know how a game plays after one hour
of gaming let's take years and years of
war for example the new the new gears 5
you you if
if you play the first act you will not
like it as much as if you get to the
second one because you gaming things
starts but that you don't reach it after
one hour right so yeah let me tell you
something when you playing Kingdom Come
deliverance the game really picks up six
hours in I'm talking about really meat
and potatoes of the game and it is such
a when I saw go to game pass that's why
I was so happy when you got on
when I saw go to game pass I swear i DM
kognito I said they made it because so
important care but is and of course we
have returning our most technical gaming
Lord the solo gamer who lives for the
single player selfish experience and
also the sastra Damas mister or flat
profile Illuminati and Lord patron of
the iron bake my man Lord sovereign
finally back how you doing sir what's
going on a good morning good morning
good morning how are you today sir are
you waffles and stuff I did I went away
before we saw early man we still haven't
breakfast waffles
listen I could do 9:00 a.m. if you want
we just say the word hit the button get
him out of here
we got a lot of things to talk about
have you got a chance to do much gaming
this week sir not too much not too much
I'd play some gears uh a little bit
yesterday just did the intro part and
then I played a little bit of Act one
today literally like maybe 2025 minutes
Wow already shut out the downloaded
kingdom come
you see my apologies I wasn't here you
fraud turn your camera on yes I agree
I've brought us off because he had one
of the best interviews with Toby for
woman's life kita good leg Toby doesn't
even get to see if it Toby long when I
tell you that you don't want to see this
Toby trust me I am in bed in a
wife-beater with my coke bottle glasses
on
you already got me back I don't want you
to stay away calling himself King I've
played it I played my PC I've been on my
did you did you play Blair Witch on PC
sir the way she's on if we can't play on
my exit don't need to be played at all
I'm gonna let you know that right there
so don't tell me I got a love game past
PC equally you can't be captain game
pass and love only one PC game
I love you want to get to the switch and
of course I played Astro off the chain
you know that so that's a lot to play
now let me ask you a question
being that you were here last week um
how do you like it because I don't like
the fact that what people are doing
right now I am really going on these
lame excuses for people that always want
to these gaming sites for the latest
score
and how they want to play again cuz if
it ain't a 90 I can't touch it baby
both peppadews and look for somebody to
tell him what's fun and was good I had a
food taste those people that's pick him
up apps and and telling them what to
watch and what does he and and how to
think and how to move I don't move like
that and you know astral chain has been
getting bagged and broken but I heard is
a real good game could you please
explain to these people what actual
training is it's an excellent game made
if there's certain things about it that
are simplistic it comes in a combat um
but I think the point is to use your
your your slave it's kind of be a slave
in combat and it's it's a matter of how
you use your Legion so I mean for me I
can I can understand people waiting for
reviews to sort of gauge if they're
gonna purchase something or not because
you know sixty sixty five bucks it's a
lot you know you don't want to spend it
and then not love the game so I get that
at the same time like I'm not with that
if it's a night if it's not a ninety
above I'm not playing that because
you're missing out on you know whatever
two-thirds of the games that come out
every single generation if you do that
like honestly the best games out of them
if you want me to read your stuff or you
knew that slander put it in color
someone else land up with a fairly flat
I can't read it though
if isn't color definitely shout it out
so yeah man like I don't listen you need
people need to go out there and figure
things out for themselves do not go
taking people's opinions as doctrine um
you know you can get a gauge overall
from different types of opinions and
maybe do that but man like if you're
you're with that 90 or above or I'm not
playing it you're missing out a lot if
you realize like if you only play 90 and
above games you've played like three
four games this year
okay you play Resident Evil 2 you played
I think shark ro got a 90 a that's
awesome like this year not to mention
numbers quo
yes and not to mention the fact that
number scores mean nothing like there's
so much subjectivity to this as personal
and personal I think the only time you
should go by Metacritic score or any
kind if if it's a franchise you don't
normally play you just want a general
interest of the commute that the
industry itself feels like that's a good
game or not and then you should look at
you know if you go on there and it's
like a 55 it's a good chance you might
not like that game but but you know that
there are certain games like um dying
light that God didn't get the greatest
one I mean got like in the 70s I think
but it was an amazing game so like there
are there exceptions yeah also and that
you cannot trust the numbers anyway
anymore because the that's a way bigger
problem there there you need to consider
their social politics as well imply that
numbers are not the same as they were
and that's what I feel that certain
title certain types of games will get
Etra numbers if they have something in
it and certain times of game will get
worse numbers if they lack something in
it which is not necessarily a quality
addition or or feature whatever but more
like a social politics something well
mm-hmm you need to heavily consider
which number you are trusting and which
not so saying I play only 19 a buff is
really that's you cannot guarantee that
it's 90 game you are trying it's really
your cup of tea and it's good let's say
that and the same applies for movies as
well you have the the the the critics
who give a certain movie let's say the
let's say Star Wars or whatever really
relatively high numbers but then you
have cracks and the people who really
dig into it and understand these kind of
movies and
criticises from a different perspective
and they say it's the worst that was
ever released so the numbers are a good
indicator if if the game is super crap
or not but I would say everything above
six of five or six is definitely
playable everything below five and six
is something where you should at least
think twice because there might be a
reason why it but if you if you take it
for example Kingdom Come deliverance
which I mean we have these problems
yeah we're giving us high numbers Aloha
numbers because of other reasons than
the game itself mm-hmm I get really
annoyed by the yeah I mean I this we
don't we don't find anyone if if they
feel like that's represent this numbers
representative for the type of game then
so be it but then you also have that's
the media side but then you also have
the angry mob side right so what people
laughing but in the last year's or well
what two three four years it's a
relatively young thing the review
bombing things yes that's exactly what I
was getting into when you said that that
mentality a review bombing and and
bringing a score to see this is letting
you know that that that aspect of a
score being held by a group of people
that you can't control when they bomb
something and they bring the score down
to either zero or below its natural
level then that upsets the apple cart
right so what's gonna happen is soon
they're gonna remove that whole program
from you and you know how like they go
to like Nielsen ratings and stuff like
that there's only in the select houses
and people get to check and see what is
good and what is bad and it's only gonna
be a select few you're gonna give up all
your control and give it to only a
select few and then it's gonna go to the
part with only like these fifty people
there's gonna start dictating what the
scores are
mmm-hmm opposed to the populace you know
saying what the scores should be and
just like Toby said maybe if a game
doesn't have blood in it or it doesn't
have this it has a lowest score because
these people feel it should have you
know I say touch stuff see it and see if
you like hey I hate when people judge
and review a game off of what's not in
the game like it's like if it was never
in the game how you gonna review it like
it is in the game know something against
the game for for not including what you
want in it like did at that point you're
just throwing objectivity out the window
right and it's like what it's not a way
that I wanted to be it's trying to
justify the opinion of what's going on
like at the other day always always
judged by what's in you know people
attended out of ten I feel would be
something that said that's not a little
bit it's a wee extreme buddy sorry buddy
and it's definitely something where I
get really I don't trust this number
usually when I see a ten out of ten
like I am or I will pick that weight
like let's say I'm reviewing a game and
everyone's giving you the tonight of ten
I'm gonna be like alright it for some
reason that's automatically gonna drop
because I'm expecting up here and it's
not up there like a ten out of ten it
doesn't necessarily mean the gates
perfect it means out of ten it achieved
everything that gang was trying to
achieve at the best possible way could
of a chip I mean listen I'll make this
quick as we are going really long in
this town okay own thing to me is just
look ten into ten if I see that you know
yes my eyebrow raises is one of them
things while my if it's that it has to
be at that point not only the game with
a generation but something that changed
gaming that at that point had never been
done before
until that game came out you know I'm
saying like that is like true
transformative kind of moment as far as
the review stuff it's like look at the
end
they this is all subjective and I'm
saying they're gonna be people who come
into a genre or a game already with a
with a predisposition about whether they
like it or not you know I'm saying at
the end of the day is that for you to
look at or aggravate all the scores that
you look for from people that you trust
that either like the type of games that
you like and then that kind of will
judge your make your decision process
but I think we put too much weight on if
someone gave something a score that we
disagree with and that shouldn't affect
your day Ling I love a game there's
nothing no one's gonna tell me I don't
can't be got a six a five if I'm play I
love it I'm playing it and I'm not gonna
stop so this is where I got with it look
we gotta got to get a lot of show to get
on we got Toby stuff to talk about
I know we gonna talk about reviews at
some point so I'm good yeah know what
else to touch a little bit of Astral
train and yeah just been messing around
but us off real quick I know we got some
giveaways to do are you ready for that
sir I'm absolutely ready that's my mic
ready let's go first we're gonna pay
some bills to take care of our patreon
subscribers and of course we got some
giveaways to give away all right so
let's run through our patreon
subscribers and give thanks as we do
every single month and we're gonna start
with our friend to the realm Lord meds
thank you sir for all the love and of
course I'll forever patron from up on
high Lord Korey lydic aka Lord whiskey
thank you sir ways with us brother
always always followed by Lord slow-mo
of the back slap followed by Lord HB 33a
Kay Lord Hakeem salute thank you sir
followed by a friend and fellow youtuber
Lord Nintendo Direct
thank you sir the Emperor thank you sir
and I think he's in the Lords of gaming
fantasy football today oh all right
mm-hmm that money okay
or stitch 66 69 the hater of switch
topics post a shot - Justin Russell
right now found our super chat Lords
what do you guys think about the blatant
gambling an NBA 2k 20 yeah it's pretty
aggressive man it's pretty pretty
aggressive got slap cheating it's kind
of rough continues right now that that
loot boxes are gambling and they are
putting in the slot machine right that's
a good idea let's do that you got
exactly just put in a gambling
institution in your game that's all no
boxes all right next up we have Lord
vagabond oh thank you sir for the
support
followed by Lord gaming Forte foretaste
of the chat was going on my brethren and
of course friend to the realm Lord
undead 3xb eye and true king of the No
smile man undead salute on they're
making expected and take network doubt
no doubt
next up we have Lord linchpin ports
German brother man
/i lovely followed by the Lord of X
cloud himself Lord bills still well
people and we have our very first patron
Lord monkey punch himself anyone well
that's my day one brother that's what's
up slow mo said o was his bride receipt
for the giveaway Lord saw he's just
checking if he bribed you correctly so
you can be the bag was received this
time
nowhere keep driving the iron bank and
maybe your name perhaps good things will
happen I don't know any and all
conversations will be entertained by the
man who does put his government and
everything that's good savvy Prescott
alright and we have Lord Max Payne to
k91 aka night music followed by a family
to the realm the grounded gamer himself
Lord next up we have the king of the
stream team and ban hammers all across
the land himself special shout out in a
sec my family from the cradle to the
grade Lord em bird himself loaded pixels
alright next we have Lord CDF
s underscore look too cold and of course
we have stored tai chi coming up salut
followed by Lord J Pereira 99 reviews
are the best salute aigoo brother really
means a lot man thank you for your
support much appreciated and of course
last but certainly not least our brother
from across the pond Lord death singer
himself you K we need to get back on my
brat basement radio arcade podcast with
the 20 that Wow thank you brother
salute iron Lords gears 5 is a must play
for anyone who holds an xbox it's the
best gear since again as a weird three
oh I can't do the Spanish yeah yeah yeah
to savage serious network issues [ __ ]
shame on Comcast but anyway yeah
shoutout to the $4 super chat from from
JD gamer I choose a good show that the
Lord's deliver every is always time
dependent I love the [ __ ] you you guys
do that that low how you do brap brap I
love the fact how you win bilingual
and you know we can give a little
education and that's Spanglish let's
throw that up in there that's right
[Laughter]
patreon giveaways with our $10 gift card
giveaway what $10 gift card giveaway Oh
Lord
all right the algorithm is doing good
Louis I think it's working as it should
no guys good stuff all right now let's
get to this $20 gift card giveaway and
the winner of our $20 gift card giveaway
a lord night music wow listen anybody
this new log in join up do guys winning
right now alright and now finally we
have our teespring giveaway all righty
all right all right
and the winner of our monthly teespring
give away a Lord Michael this is rig
slow boy you got a bird alright so now
now that that's concluded once again
thank you to all our loyal patrons for
supporting each and every month you guys
we really have no idea what this means
to us we really really appreciate that
and now we're gonna get into our gleam
giveaway DOS big ones oh oh no big ones
the
the Lord's gave to we're giving out two
games at a time this time around got
some you know you know how the fall
season is we have a lot of big games so
before I do a big thank you and shout
out to the Lord of the stream team and
the king of the ban hammers Lords now
though himself as as kognito was saying
earlier people will do anything to win a
$65 game multiple accounts fraudulent
accounts fraudulent accounts all type of
stuff and Loras now though goes through
each and everything making sure that we
have a legitimate winner every single
time we do these so thank you Lord Snell
though for all the help and again also a
message from Lord snow though guys that
listen to the iron Lords podcast that
don't usually enter this guy's enter
these contests this is for you this is
to show love for the support you guys
give us so I mean honestly we we love
the support we get all over the place
but if one of you guys that we know
listens to us all the times and show
support all the time wins we're that
much happier so get in there absolutely
do that alright okay so let's go with
our borderlands 3 winner Borderlands
launches this week let's go and the
winner of our gleam borderlands 3
giveaway is
lord howe mesh at yahoo.com there are no
other I have no other way to describe
I'm not gonna give out your name whole
mess at yahoo.com congratulations I will
contact you later today with your
information and your code so you've been
pre download borderlands 3 and be ready
for when it launches i believe them on
the 12th or the 13th it's one of those
two days mm-hmm
so congratulations to lord howe mesh now
the winner of our gears 5 giveaway is a
baby let's go for big one
Lord Easy Mac BB at gmail
see y'all didn't get in
y'all get that easy that mag DB must be
a fan of death stranding since he's put
a BB in his Gmail all the winners
congratulate for everyone that signed up
man huge supporter really appreciate it
we also got some Kingdom Come stuff
there's some iron ore harvest are we
doing during the show okay yeah stay on
you got like I said we got Toby in the
building we're gonna be doing some cool
giveaways man like I said for those who
haven't guy Kingdom Come deliverance and
iron harvest it is going to be late so
please you guys gonna be getting some
cool stuff man stick with us throughout
the duration of the show no doubt so
that's what we got saw this has the idol
gang been fulfilled
the iron bank is closed for business for
the day of unless of course bribes and
you know and we're always open for
business
out the chief Thomas are y'all giving
out emails we got all the Patriots fault
therefore out the way you know say I
want to start with Lord Toby his video
game system history gaming and Germany
in the Czech Republic and his journey in
a gaming industry and of course what led
him from becoming the community manager
to then the PR manager for warhorse
Studios so Lord Toby let's start from
the very beginning where the first game
systems you had and what got you into
gaming the first one I played I didn't
own it by but my but my cousin owned it
which means that it was in the families
it was a Amiga 2600 so all I started
very early games the big black box the -
yes joke joke joke on sir how do you
call them - Jake exactly so this was the
the first console I played and I can
I didn't I can't remember how the name
was of the game where you were there
were there were
three crocodiles in the water and they
were all there more than you amazing I
like that a lot but the the the console
the platform that sticked to my heart
yes go up to today and that's why I was
crying tears of joy yesterday and oh hey
before is the Super Nintendo well it's
here in the studio somewhere I have an
original one still I it's probably in
the in the kitchen where the people play
so I original packet Wow
that's his father that's only the
controller but I have the original stuff
for everything from the Nintendo my
favorites platform and now that Nintendo
Direct or the Nintendo online service
offered the Super Nintendo I I was
crying a tears of joy I was a tree
playing the whole day today and right
now it's 6 p.m. in Czech Republic I was
playing Legend of Zelda Link to the Past
yeah a lot of people were very happy
about that announcement for the Superman
tears of joy it was really yes where we
talk about all the time a very powerful
system tremendous game so that was like
your baby super super Network and I can
remember I can really remember well I'm
half chicken half German so I was it
like yeah I was always traveling from
back and forth I was with my grandma in
Czech Republic and then with my family
in Germany and so on and I can remember
I was like I don't know maybe maybe 7
years old 8 years old 9 years somewhere
there I was playing the Super Nintendo
in the evening and my mom came and said
shut it sleep turn it off already I
heard her and said one day I will become
a video game tester lucky thing I did
not become history but really good thing
aha I started to work in the video game
industry and
brother that's awesome that is an
awesome story system is three Super
Nintendo leading the way you don't mean
so now now do we know obviously you got
a background in game you play games and
love games but as far as like now
transitioning into the gaming industry I
know like initially your background you
had like a lot of reporting and on a
journalistic side and then on in fact
yeah then what kind of want to know like
from that then what leads you to that
activity become a community manager for
well we know in Italy do you mean like
well I don't know it's the most points
but many boys at least in my and my
friendship bubble they love game so
video games was an essential part of my
life all the time however I also played
something that is not very popular in
the USA it's called handball and it's a
ball ball but on field goals
pretty much so I played this for 20
years so sports was an essential thing
for me but at home Super Nintendo and
ice the fun thing is that you know maybe
you heard about cold cold war and stuff
and there was the Iron Curtain between
Germany and Czech Republic yes yes makes
it even weirder that I am Alive because
my mother had to flee from the Czech
Republic to the west and so on and so on
but this also means that there was no
real Super Nintendo and game Nintendo
Nintendo in general background in in the
Czech Republic so for them it was the
very first pcs they they had and they
were stolen in a way or imported from
the West so it was very tricky so after
the 90s they started with gaming but
gaming was expensive I was gonna ask you
that because III know on that side it's
it was very tough the language you guys
seem to have to go to jest the game I
know we have mods on him it's all about
you know he's from Poland he was telling
stories similar stories so like you
don't you just explained again for us on
the United States on this side of the
world like how difficult was it during
those times to actually gain to get a
hold of video
gain systems and things like that pretty
much impossible if you didn't know
anyone who was able to travel through
the border and traveling through the
border was also again impossible almost
you had to have a very good reason so
the the thing is
Iren curtain it was the fight pretty
much between the West capitalistic part
against the East communistic and the
Communists didn't want to let the people
from the communist area go to the west
and stay there and that was but this was
the big idea of most of people they
wanted to go there because they knew
that there are the products and the PCs
and the coca cola's and the beanies and
all the stuff which is completely normal
faster day to have a pirate by arity of
I don't know let's can't food let's say
for example in in the store and Czech
Republic let's say eventually five
different brands or whatever there in
the West you had 15 or whatever it I'm
just coming up with stuff but that's
that's the thing so for I was living and
born and raised in the West so I had
everything pretty much but my Daniel
Barbara the creative director here of
warhorse studios yes he get caught into
gaming way before the Iron Curtain fall
and he got he got pretty much overt
analog Amazon all the magazines where
you have to like dial and call and what
you want to order or ordered by via
postal service and then they bring your
stuff however they had magazines from
the West which of course yeah I couldn't
do anything with it but I could see the
bright pictures so these are the small
pictures of video games and PCs they
obviously have in the West and he
started to try to get get something in
in the East as well of course it was
impossible so they had smuggle it in wow
I mean art and stuff really we're
talking about giving me at all means
like yes bite our vocals despite that
thinks alright and you talk somebody
asking the question that's not what
would ever could have it's it's
something it's a little bit similar in
China as well
while China China today is censoring the
internet and Twitter and YouTube and all
this kind of stuff so that nothing harms
their way of thinking right
this tiny miss you can apply the same
through the Iron Curtain so nothing from
the West were nothing capitalistic
should harm the way of other people
there anyway that that's the one thing
but I as I said in the beginning I was
always very keen a very very keen gamer
so the Super Nintendo was by far my most
favorite come to I had a gameboy as well
so please
what portable but Super Nintendo and
then all the Playstations from one two
three four
and looking waiting for the five so I
was a PlayStation guy not an analogy of
getting into the game path I studied I
studied five years of journalism so I'm
with the master degree journalist and I
always thought that I always thought
that asking questions and writing them
down is exactly what I'm best at and my
university they the topic I studied
split up into PR and to journalists and
I journalist method ok I would do the
journalist in part because PR that's
crap only only only I don't know girls
do it or whatever that's what I want to
do and then I found out that I'm way bit
and answering questions excellent I I
got into the gaming industry because I
was working as a journalist as a
freelancer and I was slowly bleeding out
because well I lived by that time
already in Czech Republic because I
studied my master studies I did them
here however I'm not really able to
write and check which is a big problem I
speak fluently and I can read fluently
as well I cannot write without mistakes
though automatically mistakes which as a
journalist is pretty bad so I had
bandaged that I couldn't write my own
articles I could dictate it to someone
and they should write it down oh you had
a secretary for a while for a while it
worked well but of course you had to
argue a lot and with us to make them pay
you anyway even though we need a second
person to do the job of one person right
so it was pretty difficult and I was
bleeding out of money because it's
freelancer job so I was and it was right
after University I so I still like to
lay on the couch rather than every
morning and get to get to work and at
one day I met a little bit chubby
bearded guy in our apartment elevator
I saw him already several times and say
who the hell is he and this one day we
step into the elevator foot together and
he was like hey what's up my name is
Daniel are you living here I said yeah I
live on the top ok I'm Daniel Barbara
some words or the name today is familiar
I that ring the bell I had no idea so I
was on I was when I went to my apartment
and googled him mm-hmm and I need to hit
me like like an arrow like a week before
I saw him in German television where he
was introducing his new Kickstarter
project Hingham come deliver his life
and he just opened oh well it was open
already but he they just did the
Kickstarter and it became somewhat
famous I was like ok ok ok Toby
concentrate that you have one shot right
so I know the was to display just what
they're looking for so they looked only
for programmers and these kind of stuff
everything I can't not do so there's
like technical stuff crap [ __ ] what I'm
going to so I let it slip for a week or
so and always like checked it like if
they if they have something new if
they're looking for something because I
wanted to actually I I because he was
living below me I wanted to sneak on or
or spy on
because he had a kid and a dog and he
was regular walking both so I will just
bump into him again because we are
living in a flat built in a building
built in the 15th century so it's super
old building it has no elevator of
course so the elevator was stuck outside
and it's a glass elevator and I tried to
actually see he's going really weird
creepy stuff however I love it though
this is the links we have to do for
gaming let's just go go go a little shy
you have to go to your like zag lungs go
and I wanted to actually ask him out for
a beer or something by the way here's my
LP payoff to watch have a good show
there we go we got with eagle man okay
no apologies required for liking games
you like as King huh as long as you see
you got me doing this early in the
morning as long as you enjoying the
games that's all it matters it's fun
actually eagle I believe that you let me
show you time as long as you like your
stuff see a game can be 100 it can be a
90 to be all tents but if it's not in
your wheelhouse if it's something that
you don't like no one can tell you what
is fun and I'm glad that you put that in
there so thank you so much
absolutely let's get back to some fun
story with Toby let's get back for
spoken with the demo with your CD
I said CV but I don't sound
so I rap for him and gave him my rap CD
I gave him reasons to hire me no no so
that was the plan didn't work out so it
was like it was like Thursday evening
9:00 p.m. or something like that I
checked the the homepage again and they
were looking for a community manager hmm
with with media knowledge bla bla bla
and say ok that's that's up my alley
that that's something I can do so I
didn't want to wait any longer so I just
dressed printed my C CD we printed my CV
went down the stairs knocked at his door
and said hey I know who you are I love
what you do here's my CV nice and he
laughed and said it's really paid and
said don't worry I'm freelance
journalist I know what's really shitty
paid and a month later or so some weeks
later I became the community manager at
walkthroughs if you were much hosting in
June 2014
Wow first of June 2014 I became the
community manager and one year later in
June of 2015 I became became the PR
manager because we I believe it was
after the first III or while the first
is free something bad we had my first e3
we had Daniel presenting the game and I
was as a community manager sitting next
to him and playing it for him nice and I
figured that every presentation he did
was completely different than the other
the one he did before so he gave every
journalist different information or or
no information at all because he was
talking about how he was shooting with
rifles or how he was whatever doing in
his free time I was like maybe I could
try it
I might good preventing stuff and then
they said ok let's do it and anyway
pretty much from day one anyway I was in
contact with media so the community
thing was then given to someone else and
I became the PR manager but the weird
part is that with the community
background thing and me being so vocal
and loud and present that I somewhat and
that's the weird part because that's
usually PR guys are usually not very
visible right that I'm also doing all
the interviews and news and whatever you
most like you said most people I kind of
sometimes they take the bag that a
community badge yes they would take the
front
yes but the PR usually try and take the
back but you can at unique mix where you
are in the front you're in the streams
your visits you know me now is everyone
who is cool with this your level of
outgoingness
this is lights talking it was an optical
once and it was called when when when
creeping paid out tell you something in
every aspect you have to go and you have
things I mean you don't you know he was
an overbearing he wasn't you know
listening to the guys doing that stuff
but he did was time his bumps yes you
know so timing your bumps to get your
job to see that hey how are you today or
whatever and you know what here's my CD
man listen man listen curriculum returns
my CV sounds better with CD get out of
the trunk literally a freestyle rap
would try to get a deal like that was we
talking about the due diligence of
believing in yourself so much that you
put yourself out there and he timed his
bumps and his bumps time down it was
right listen guys don't give up on your
dreams
I mean he's telling you he went up the
chain by the time and his bump to meet
and greet and to be out there trust me
it works out this fantastic but keep
going it was really great speech man at
one
thing I would please also if don't don't
have the attitude of I cannot do that
Oh and that is too hard for me or I'm
probably not the right know just try it
you can always apply always try it the
things you can you you are maybe not
able to do right now is something you
might be learning throughout your job
and every stream CV is always not the
not necessarily the requirements only
but it's also the optimal person I like
that
which even if you're applying for a job
which requires you to have a driving
license or whatever and you don't have
it you still might just try it and maybe
they figure out hey this guy it's
actually good for this other job we
don't have yet written so we always I
don't like this you mean you have to you
have to have this I can do it attitude
and that's what what drags me through
life I guess no that's a great point I
mean you're totally Nellie because
there's many positions like that that um
like I said you may look at it on face
value on paper so I might not qualify
but you still have other skill set and
then you go and even if you don't even
if you get that job which is great but
if you don't get that job sometimes in
the future they can remember what your
skill set is and there's a position that
even more tailored to you so never give
up I totally agree with that mentality
there's been jobs like that in nineteen
that I've kind of come across with
similar you know similar type of results
and situations and things have happened
but man tremendous man tremendous on
that story and I was like wow magic can
and it can even be the weirdest stuff I
can remember back then and when I was
still in university I was working as a
video journalist so I was doing the
camera and stuff I can remember that I
had some series up there and my
colleagues they there was one CV they
were pretty much almost all of those
guys had the same skill set and there
was some somewhat the same and they
picked the one who had in his hobbies
beekeeping just ended this sounds funny
I know but that just because it was so
different and special that they said
beekeeping that's interesting let's
invite so I know that sounds funny and
weird but I
it just supports what you just said that
you can your skillset the weird as weird
as it could be theoretically it can be
just the one thing that triggers some
interest
[Music]
salute to sexy biscuit in the chat I was
not that's a big support right so real
quick bears are being lit been
tremendous story I was like you said um
you know obviously we've talked about
Kingdom Come deliverance on I love
podcasts at nauseam we all love the game
we know we call it real life Skyrim you
know no no just no drag is nothing that
just based on real medieval history with
eating drinking you know ultra realistic
sensibilities so the question I got for
you told me it's like the way I look at
you guys you are the epitome of the
underdog story right you guys are enough
as a Kickstarter you know you know you
get the fun and you get to that level
and then you get to this level of this
critically acclaimed beloved game starts
off almost with a coke classic to now
multiple DLCs to now our Royal Game of
the Year Edition right so my question to
you Toby and war like what's the feeling
in the studio like what's the energy to
see cuz you've been there for the
beginning you you you put your CV out
when this thing was you know just a
dream I thought you know so what's the
energy of the studio right now so I
started the team I applied at the team
when they had 25 people here when I came
we we stopped it up to 40 so as I said
in 2014 now when I look into the studio
we have a hundred and thirty people here
I think within five years so what's the
energy so definitely there's a lot of
punk rock in and in the best sense I
mean in this studio so they we a lot of
people have this feeling of we are
different than most other companies
because of the underdog story there's no
there was no now we have a big publisher
there but there was no big publisher was
dictate
us you have to do X why's that because
that pace or something that no we had
some ideas we developed them someone
said it's crap we said no we'll do it
anyway nice and in the end it turned out
good so right now what we do is that in
the studio we have some what about I
don't know 30 40 people who ever did a
video game before other than to come
deliverance yeah
so the the made majority of the team is
young guns people from the universities
people and the end that again supports
what we just said people who never had
like gaming job before and apply with
some kind of skill set and we believe
that okay he's good enough and the rest
we will teach him so the energy is
pretty high and pretty rebelling still
however it all we'd have a big publisher
behind us media or deep server this
might change something so about her so
so far everything is super cool we have
a really great relation to finger
crimper fingers crossed everything stays
that it is but aside and I see a bright
future future so it's awesome man we've
known for you guys man this is this is
you guys got picked up obviously at a
deep civil relationship the THQ
relationship we were just like wow they
are going places they should be around
for a while and it's good to see because
again it's a very great feeling no one
really told us but we feel like that we
are one of the major studios anyway from
deep server know so no one said it like
that just now put your chest out told
you you can do it keep saying it to
ourselves we will ours do you teach Q
school so I feel we are in the right
corner there yeah yeah when we went to
pax and we had you guys scheduled for
the interview and we got over there and
we saw you guys it's I know I can't
explain the feeling because you get to
see something from his Genesis from its
inception his growth right and the next
time we saw you at PAX again it was
larger growth like the first growth is
you know you go see your flowers and
your flowers is growing and then the
next time you go and they're budding and
they're producing more pollen and
growing all over and I said wow this
this makes me feel really good because
we saw them grow into this big you know
like you said it's over 100 some are
people there now it is totally different
and you can see how because you knew the
game was great when we saw a Cognito
made sure that that was our first
interview then we got there
you know and you know that was how the
energy was there everything was there
that we knew the studio believed in what
they were doing yes and then we got the
game and then again was like oh it's
like Kingsfield this is crazy and it was
so much fun and we every every person we
came across we talked about it what made
it so important is the second time we
saw you guys in the video went viral
yeah that's when I said I love that part
that's because it was organic it wasn't
it was perfect and that that's a big
shout-out to sexy biscuit for that
because she took that video and they and
they ran with it they took that video
and ran with it and really made it
something big it's special but I tell
you like one thing I noticed from the
onset I wasn't there the first time you
guys met Rick
but it's like I met both Rick and Toby
and what you if you don't know any
better you would swear both to these
guys with Deb's
yes that's how well they know they may
knew that game in front side outwards
and and as somebody who's at this point
now interviewed a lot of devs and your
managers at at events level saw right
yeah there's levels this I've seen PR
managers that don't know a damn thing
about their game like it's you know
there and then and then Toby and Rick
like it was just like boom boom boom
this is you square they were devs and
that that is so especially to somebody
when they're first going out there doing
interviews that is such a comforting
thing to know that every question that
you have is not going to be met with the
blank stare
like you know that you're getting again
an answer and an in-depth answer
absolutely if we again just absolutely
tremendous and like a king said it best
like it's one of its like believing in a
child and then you watch that child grow
and we've seen you guys in that journey
and I'm just like wow they're doing it
man this is this is so cool just to be a
part of that journey with you guys has
been tremendous I wonder I want to move
on real quick cuz I gotta ask a question
I don't know Gamescom had came up and
the thing that surprised me which is the
cherry on the sundae Tori I gotta ask
you was um the announcement on inside
Xbox with you guys in game pass like was
huge cuz I'm sitting there to myself I'm
just like so many people will now get a
chance to play this gem you don't have
either heard about maybe they couldn't
afford it at the time but they have game
Pass so my question to you was like you
know that about that decision and then
how beneficial is it for a developer
because we hear this all the time you
know you know about game going in the
game pass is it really good for the game
like how did that meat work out for
warhorse for you guys for putting it in
you know what what I am asking myself is
very often the same question for example
with the new gears I for example I I
don't I literally don't know how the
deaths up hate now because people who
have and I'm not the deficit I mean
generally usually you buy a game for
eggs and then you get a certain and then
you can say okay it's successful owner I
don't know how gears does it because
it's right from the start in the xbox
game past for us it's it's it's more of
and this sounds ugly if I say them but
it's more like a marketing thing of we
don't expect to earn any money or any
big money from Kingdom Come anymore
which was it's just it's just hitting
it's it's just like all right yeah in
the cycle right its end of the cycle the
dlc out the next thing is the the
morning coming up and the x-box game
pass is actually a really really amazing
thing exactly as you said to get it
among the people again
those who said I don't want to pay a
plate or it doesn't have the 9100 I will
not play nine or 90 or above so well for
us is just a great way to get it among
the people and and just grow the
community in a way so we have for
example Seabiscuit who's in the indicate
in the chat who's still doing great
videos about kcd we have new coming on
on the jumping on the bandwagon it was a
good thing we were approached in a way I
think by Microsoft if I can own some
kind of discussion I would you like to
yes we would like to what's necessary
and so on and yeah and I'm super happy
to be among those who huge as titles on
the egg so amazing yeah basic what you
say it almost like from a marketing
standpoint from a visibility standpoint
like you say you at the end of the cycle
you know normally the kind of games will
fade away a little bit at that point cuz
you're just doing mods and other stuff
at that point but now it's almost like
you said gears 5 is out and then on that
same marketing storefront you're right
Kingdom Come delivers just right here
with all these major ties so again a
whole bunch of eyes a whole new audience
that may have missed that title now
because their subscriber to game pass
they have access their privy and
hopefully engagement I would assume you
don't mean would increase with that with
your title I well it's a exactly as you
say it's like they say I don't know if
it's just for me like that if the page
knows that I am doing or looking for kcd
or something but if I open the game pass
the library and click on all in the case
it is the first the first thing I I
don't know if that's if the browser
knows that I mean the browser's
predisposed to you know what what you
guys are on is the first page like the
game that was released for that month
right what I noticed was Kingdom Come
deliverance was right there I was kind
of pissed off because I was like yeah I
pay for it I got all this stuff is it
you know we were supported from day one
in
really didn't matter at all but the fact
that other people there's you know
couldn't like like kognito said couldn't
either afford it or didn't know on met
many games came on let's say you came
out in a month that three games came out
and somebody only had enough money for
two great so now they're able to get
this game you said it's at the end of
the lifecycle but that that end of the
life cycle is the beginning of the life
cycle and game past you understand and
in that beginning of that life cycle
will transcend because you got millions
of people that probably have game paths
that will say wow you know this is a
real robust game it is not a short game
by any stretch of the imagination
fledged alright is a full-fledged
meat-and-potatoes game i told you about
a fourth or fifth hour of you into the
game that's when the game really starts
to get its meat and potatoes going so
when i saw it i was like um it was very
different from what was in game past
because game you pass had a lot of games
in there probably top out with 10 hours
of gameplay your game is well past ten
hours of gameplay and it mean to be
inside game past i thought it was a real
achievement to be on the pitch it's a
huge honor it's a huge honor i you guys
we were talking about games come earlier
i was invited by Microsoft to be on the
Microsoft Xbox game past stage and the
stage was it's an honor that I'm still
being invited
a year after released walk on the stage
about the game that it's a year old so
the huge honor and it's really great
it's really really great if you or there
are always haters of course and if you
see some haters saying yeah the game
passes it's not attractive enough or so
what's really cool is that most of the
comments below it say say something like
what you're talking about there's crazy
games like ears yes he should have wore
whatever job be in quesadilla among the
cool games so they know you yeah the
cool game tell your names and lights man
you're up there with the big boys in
game fast shot at the Sun although with
the final super chair hello my Lords
good morning and welcome back sir Toby
he loved meeting you at PAX love the war
products everyone should get them salut
now though behind the camera that got
you on camera Mandy story man and ask
thanks this great absolutely last but
not least obviously we know about you
know iron harvest that's the new kind of
Tyler you've been talking about so again
you don't get new role without King our
schemes and Koch media needs fasting
silver so I guess my question just real
quick if you briefly for those who don't
know what is the premise of iron harvest
what is it about what why should we get
excited about iron harvest so just very
quickly just to clarify first so again
coach media or Deep Silver is the mother
company their videos exactly no I am
still the PR manager at war hostages
that's very important but because
Cassidy there's nothing to be released
anymore the modding marketing and PR and
stuff is is going down of course so deep
server said hey Toby you're doing an
okay job you have a number we have
another product here called iron harvest
would you be interested I said great
thing I'll do it
why and that's now coming because iron
how this is an RTS which I when I
remember PC gaming I I think I started
with RTS first command conquer June 2000
Warcraft 1 and 2 yes I did never played
the third one actually so I played one
and two Age of Empires of course Age of
Empires 1 was absolutely absolutely
mind-blowing at the door was amazing the
volu loci of everyone amazing
so RTS is part of my DNA anyway so IRA
novice is one of those RTS as though
it's nothing for it's nothing like the
games I played back then have you guys
played a company of heroes yes yeah iris
is a company of hero of heroes esque
game what I mean and then based combat
system you it's a cover
system so you cannot blindly send your
troops to the front line they will most
likely die so it's more like you have to
really send them from cover to cover to
cover
they're already mainly this is IRA now
is actually and that's not I'm not
saying that because I'm the PR guy for
that but I'm saying really it's the most
strategic or tactical RTS from all the
routine or take the guard yes as I
played in the recently is to Company of
Heroes it's somewhat in the same la we
are talking here about alternative
history universe about World War one max
so you have those Omega so we got world
war but we got max going on to we have
big messes so we have World War one but
with giant mechs and it's actually it's
a alternative universe created by a
polish painter called yaku Podolski
that's not so important but he created
this universe and based on this universe
which has factions already and heroes
and everything so this world's already
living based on that king art games from
germany a german studio decided to make
a RTS out of it video game so as I said
stress a strategic tactical cover based
and with giant max groaning you got max
going on during the great war 19th ways
you got his little dieselpunk vibe I'm
feeling yes wait you got be told more so
let me ask you a question because I'm
visualizing the game in my head um can
ya guys take cover behind the mechs legs
of the mix big enough that they can hide
behind and you can rest recover or a
clever question so there's different
sizes of Max mmm-hmm you cannot directly
cover behind your Mac so they are big
enough to dispute the biggest class of
Max is big enough to destroy cover and
just walk through buildings and stuff so
yeah but when those mechs go down so if
they're destroyed or something they will
leave their parts
lying around and right behind them you
can you they are they can be a tactical
advantage but they can also be a
disadvantage because if they lie is lay
somewhere they can you can maybe not
cross them anymore so you need to
destroy them first because before you
continue with your graphic units or you
let leave it there and leave the
opponent deal with it so if you if you
destroy that some rich or something for
example you might present anymore before
he destroys those guys wow this sounds
really cool man chat is getting ghosted
supreme says sign me up look to coast as
RTS I'm in adore RTS games with joke I
converted to PC earlier this year I love
them so when can do people get their
hands on this man about this what's
going on that's that's the sad story so
iron love is the second name of iron
Havas this iron harvest 1920 plus I
don't know if you can see it
that's the name iron harvest 1920 plus
and the reason each day is the first of
September 20 so 1 9 20 in way of putting
the date 1 9 20 I to it alright so we
got a little while but uh it's pretty
much attic back Atticus off there
because we maybe you hear me yeah I can
hear you man we got we may have some
things yes sided let's read that super
chat from dizzy King owes me like Julio
got paid you might be onto something but
it's more like a be gone to the pages no
knees involved sorry so we got no way
but we may have some exactly so uh Lord
a do you dare are you are we able to get
that yeah I think you should give it to
sagas my I don't know comcast is in the
bushes right now I'm gonna go ahead and
put it in the IOP Ches off and you can
get Roy solve you got that taken care of
for us because we want people are hungry
for some iron harvest a like the way
this sounds man are you putting it are
you putting it in hang up and putting a
mule he's gonna put it in aisle peach a
tall person chef okay and they can see
that they would just touch that is that
the people you know we can't
have you seen have you guys seen the
game opening night life the games come
conference I did see the games Jenny Lee
did it and and it was because games come
now that III is sinking ship games who
wants to be that no I'm glad you said
that that was the vibe I felt games come
felt like an extract it felt like how
III supposed to feel and obviously we
know what's been going on with the ESA
and everything it's kind of been on it
down Gamescom man I'm glad you said but
continued continued story with Keighley
yes and well III I mark my words next
year will be big because of the consoles
and the new world placed it next after
that sinking ship
but anyway games come try to be more
international now so they had this
opening night life they flew Cillian and
they want to make it like even bigger
than it is anyway already and on the
opening night life deep server offered
me hey Toby how about you have a
presentation on stage and was like oh
that would be hmm it would be the cherry
on the cake side of my career and then
they said oh well unfortunately they
said we cannot have a stage show only
the Japanese guys can go there feel
small and certain but you can have a
video so at least something we have a
video on the opening night lab with iron
harvest I don't know if I can send a
link in the in the in the alright so
that first alpha code is out it's in the
chat jump in there man first iron
harvest code is in there man we got
stuff going on also we got some kcd
Royal additions going on so make sure
you get that to solve as well okay yeah
they're all there you just can't just
let me know when you want me to drop it
it's a good cake
I cannot wait till we get a chance to go
to Germany and sit Toby at a pub I would
love to show you around where are you
guys anyway located I never found out we
we met in Boston but where's you we
reversed of us Harbor East Coast New
York West Virginia but um so we're
predominantly the east coast of the
United States New York City yes I've
never been to you know you know in New
York and I'm only usually only traveling
to the u.s. aim to go to cover one of
those events so hopefully then I hope
that I but I can say that I can see your
crib hopefully play New York
oh yeah next year is as huge as we hope
it to be and listen there's s a new
trade show out of New York with video
games all over the place is a very good
event is very fantastic and it's growing
it's blossoming and hopefully it can get
to like how packs is and yeah and you'll
be there because I'm telling you our you
know that--just Studios going nowhere
it's definitely gonna be around for a
long time to come yeah you guys are
gonna be around we definitely seen play
New York City that's on the rise
obviously we met you a couple times at
PAX you know as well yeah it's gonna
happen as that that's the little
question it's later sweetmeat right pax
pax a toast in the Lord's and it'll be
something yes
so we meet latest on march in - and
watch hopefully what about you guys come
is that too far no no no your blaster
will go will fly we are just working out
the logistics United States
I feel uncomfortable doing Toby you see
the two faces you see here right those
are the two faces you will see again I'm
actually I'm actually all fantastic is
that Sun Prairie
I think you wanna let me know here and
I'll let you know
do you see our faces we would definitely
be getting off the plane just like this
so that we got a slot show to get into
we'll move on last question if we ask
all the guests just a fun little
question Toby top five video games of
all time that is super hard
now if I'll make it easy if I'm hurt oh
I'm unprepared okay so he's over bad
alright so what I'll say is this to make
it easier for you you can also you can
cheat and say a franchise like for
example I know you mentioned pitbull I
know you met a couple of game but
franchises I'm not a fan of franchises
or so specific game let's go so I can't
it's not a specific order it's not one
to five but like most it's definitely
XCOM - OH
first game in my mind I guess my best
friend right now that is legendary
that's all about less XCOM always let's
go it's amazing yes so a game I love it
I really love it it's a grand search
strategy game from Paradox Interactive
it's Crusader Kings - OH
mm-hmm we're hard named you if you want
to play it really good you probably have
to learn YouTube videos for the first
month first so really extremely hard to
get into but on C it's an amazing
strategy game another game not very
popular in the u.s. I guess is the
recently released I know 1,800 1,800
any strategy game where you conquer
different islands and have to get up an
economic system and feed your people in
a way so I love you see strategy
strategic stuff is somewhere that's big
NHL fan so so I hope NHL 20 will be my
new favorite one
otherwise it's nineteen is pretty good
so you guys here yes I think it's
starting to settle oh okay cool good
till you build me so we got two NHL in
their desk that stuff for you're the
first to have an NHL title besides doing
well in the in this top five it's always
selling well but relatively well but no
one confesses to like NHL NHL Crusader
Kings uh no 1800 X come to should I take
one of the old ones let's go
well I hmm well I would I would
generally say okay I said I said no
franchises but I would say it Super
Nintendo five
so whatever almost everything released
on the Super Nintendo Wii linked linked
to the past is donkey donkey kong
country due to which was great first
real card was amazing world it's so good
oh my god
you cheese island is a fool very
childish but also a very good game right
you have f-zero which was hardest yeah
do you have it
let's go you have you have the Mega
Man's which were released there as well
Castle case look at Castlevania this is
the first man who got a whole console
all right we're gonna give you the super
knee as many we could say
not say anything about any switch we
knew it that this episode could not be
over without kognito throwing that
switch or somebody played Super Nintendo
without the online mode on the plane I
would finish all those Super Nintendo
games and cannot do it I know they wish
they need to let you download this list
oh we forgot it's called we are you best
friends for life like that it's calm
it's amazing isn't it an amazing oh god
I know it's so sad when they when they
shoot down your favorite guys I think
the most part is when he panics and
throw a grenade and kill everybody
aiming at the opponent like he is 99 all
right we got it we got a two dollar
super chat from look too cold I'll
gladly pay you tomorrow for an alpha
code today right now Lord look two codes
second alpha code for iron in the chat I
gotta try it man you gotta give it a
shine a unique way that I want to give
one of the other ones well first off you
know we got we have 55 people and your
chance I like but you guys that like
bust out the snotter with the $2 which
at best
XCOM to moment is when you miss at 99%
you know what are the best X come with
that as I was actually fighting one of
the aliens Kings and no it was one of
the overseers or whatever they're called
from the last expansion I had so many
people on overwatch that they kill him
before he got out
we gotta move up and lots of trouble man
this history we got some show to do so
we get into it we'll get to pull over
real quick on last week's our people
poll results are in and the people have
spoken to the question with the early
round of previews four gears five
sounding extremely positive was the
gaming community wrong for having an
issue concerns regarding the lack of
campaign shown at e3 the winner of a
runaway 3-way ILP poll at 65% is the yes
fear mongering and its finest wait until
the game is close to release group
coming in at second place at only 20%
was that no campaign not shown at e3 was
still a huge mistake group and coming in
at last place at a 15% was the petty
Lords I don't care until I could smoke
and gaming gears last week's poll Lord
addict I know you've had a lot to say
about this what do you think about the
results and the people have spoken
let me tell you I'm going to tell you
100% addict hate me doing his voice like
that let me tell you something Mean Gene
did you just say that I say Mean Gene
yeah well you know you know the rest on
the fan this is shout-out to go supreme
people who won the poll was saying about
the gears that people were
fear-mongering so they said that waiting
to the game was released and stop
fear-mongering those are the winner of
the poll yeah definitely that those are
my peoples right there okay they might
be onto some save Ivy lattice of it
alright so we move on attic you are up I
mean I'm saying awfully which internet
stays a little strong
years five has released we gotta talk
some impressions man with you what you
feeling I know you got a lot to say on
this game and you did you and kid
screamed and I believe you complete it
so let's let's get to it man so you know
I don't I think it was Thursday with
that gear
launch for it mm-hmm so you know give it
five launched uh first off on what I
don't know who here who's played it I
want you know general impressions what
you think well you know since we don't
want to go into spoiler territory
let's just talk like the first like ten
fifteen minutes because I know sovereign
has a whole long time to play and what
your first impressions off coming off
that helicopter with all that you know
that was incredible an environment
around you know what you feelin bro
I mean first thing it's just wow the
game is beautiful like honestly the
first you know twenty minutes that I
played all of it is just eye candy it's
all of it it's like look what we can do
it's all it's all about like you know
just lighting and showing off the HDR
showing off the 4k showing off the
framerate all the stuff that they
promised it really is just a showpiece
for that and then once I got into a
firefight it was what you expect from
gear so I get you know the the the
shooting felt great especially at 60
like honestly once they give you that 60
frames per second option and gears for I
went nut and it just feels it's a
different feeling game now at this point
and I can understand 30 frames per
second for a game that that requires it
to be kind of more cinematic but this
game when you go you can go in and out
of cinemas and into gameplay seamlessly
all your the transitions their sins are
ridiculous and honestly I think 60 is
where this game needs to be moving
forward different it's so smooth just
like I mean we're so used to applauding
gears 30 so we have that 60 yeah it's a
difference good to you I that was
definitely a big difference so for me
again I don't know how the games gonna
pan out the only criticism I would have
of gears is that and I mean I would have
to see how it plays out as I play more
into the game the stuff that I heard
about you know how they in the slight
RPG mechanics and stuff like that I just
really wish from what it seems it's just
it is slight little change this is
nothing huge I would like I would like
to see for them to take even more of a
risk with that stuff but beyond that um
I would like it to move faster as well
though it's much smoother in 60fps and I
know these guys a big lumbering dudes
with a lot of armor on and stuff like
that get that but if this pace of gears
was a little bit faster I love it even
more but what do you mean faster you
have to explain that to like a third
person I want like everybody you want
them grown up on you quicker do you want
to move quicker do you want the gun
shooting quicker like I'm kind of I want
to move I want I want the movement you
look pretty fast I'm just saying I made
on its own because it's just a run it's
it's not necessary it's useful to get
from place to place but it's not
something you use actively in combat per
se so I wanted to move fast I want I
want the enemies to be able to flank me
at a certain rate like I want I just
want it to be faster like if you look at
like division 2 and how those enemies
flank you and the type of how you win
that game I want to be able to move that
way but again I get it these guys have a
lot of armor the heavy lumbering dudes I
get it
I just wish that so if you did it why do
you want to sin because addict doesn't
like nothing anything that he likes he
doesn't want to change that ever if it
was up to him you would not be acting
like you want these people moving though
you want them not like those bunny ears
off super smash brothers like I just
said a little faster but I just think
otherwise
I wanted to move that over probably
faster in this game
he's talking about but I'm pretty sure
that they toyed with that aspect of it
and even running overwatch but you if
you change the control scheme to be
honest with you you take it away from
the walking looking around because it's
an exploration in the ain't Ness I mean
that's a large part of the game that's
Rachel look we know nothing about thank
you Wow I mean coming from the dude that
put 20 minutes in the game I beater I
get you won't know nothing I had I have
more collectibles because there's if I
play for a game I want to see it in all
its glory mister Xbox 1s I want to see
the glory I want to see the prettiness
mr. Xbox how much of the game did you
actually see though you were running by
again my opinion that's all as I just
wanted to be a little fat yeah I'm
enjoying it I'm loving it I hope I think
it's gonna get better of course but I
think it's great I know you've been busy
with everything else you know I don't
know if you got a chance to at least if
you get a chance to play did you get a
chance to see it you know the reviews as
far as Gears 5 what sure are you a fan
of franchise and that really is
personally where you at with years in
general must confess that that's not up
my alley because shooters are generally
not my cup of tea though I saw very nice
things about Gears I saw I read the
reviews just as this is part of my job
knowing what's what's out there and how
other people how its received by the
people seems great seems good seems a
great continuation to long and great
Chai's though I heard I didn't didn't
play it myself I must also confess that
I don't plan to again but it it I hope
that people get to the second part
because I saw some let's plays and stuff
and the second act it seemed seems way
cooler way more interesting than the
first one either because otherwise it's
just huge cover shoot cover shoot cover
right yeah but opens up they have some
some kind of fake open world softwood
which makes me know it makes me sad
again because I really hope that having
an open world doesn't become a must-have
so you've pours it into every game wrong
with linear shooters or linear games I
don't I don't get it I mean they were
essential in our childhood and I don't
see if it's done well I don't see why
having something linear is about theis a
bad thing nom which it's a good analysis
jump into I mean look I mean I'll be
rushed out to a PT k claim and the shot
podcast I was one of those guys last
night and you're asking me about at that
time like maybe an hour to end so again
I'm kind of a little farther than soft
but you know at the end of the day I
wanted to test this game multiple ways
you know mean first you know we heard
about the graphical fidelity on the Xbox
one X and King I'm gonna be real like
when they were saying 4k 60 and all that
stuff you know something just sound nice
sounds really cool but it's something to
see that game 4k 60 frames each you it
looks like soft set it is a visual
showcase from the minute you are logged
yeah let's talk about when you in the
dark right that's the way they set you
up in the dark and then your little days
but you know flies in the air and then
they see like yo man would you get me
out of here where you have me yet and
then they dropped the doors
ah and
the world and I know when they started
this colorful world was in judgment when
everybody was you know crapping on
judgment all it sucks is this is that I
thought judgment was a visual showcase
of the colors that they can bring to the
gears world because up Attila and it was
using like different shades of grey
right right and now you see the
manifestation the growth in the game
with these colors if you don't have a 4k
television and you don't have that HDR
all you're missing a huge chunk of this
game I'm glad you said that King because
I did some testing now first of all full
disclosure you don't say obviously I
have good game pass ultimate and I'm
playing I have it on PC and I have it on
the Xbox one X so we first started Xbox
one exiled Takei shoutout to sinister
they um you know one of them with the
little robot thing and then you know two
guys it looks phenomenal right mhm
so I'm like okay cool so then I said
just cuz I gotta test it you know say so
I went over to PC now full disclosure I
do not have 4k on on PC you know saying
the effects are crazy you don't say you
can you can bump things up the at
inclusion all this stuff your friends
all it and I will say it runs smooth but
I gotta keep it I gotta stand talking
the X is right there like and again I
think it's the 4k if the HD or 4k comma
because the good from the the the
beautiful sky boxes with the bright
sunlight and then going to dark areas
and then you seeing fire it just felt
more vibrant on 4k HDR it just did does
it to me now again maybe if I had a
maximum set up on PC but I ain't willing
to spend 3 grand it was heaven mainly
then it would surpass the X but for what
the X is doing and the key is 60 frame
job
so you I don't even know how they was
able to do it to be honest based on a
CPU of the X so to me that's a great
thing and then
you know we played that I got a shout
out we played horde mode y'all shout the
slop oh yeah did you get a chance to do
cuz I heard this new thing that they got
called heroes yeah what's that about now
is that everybody has their own specific
ability and when they can do so I forgot
the guy's name is JB whatever he's kind
like a not JD that's that's Marcus son
the other got a brother he's like an
engineer so he can write his name Dell
yes that's one of my favorite he
couldn't come surprised you didn't know
that sovereign Dell is like hey TV don't
even anything before K in HD of Snyder's
I have a 4k TV it is so fun and they
shot the car he's having so much fun as
the little what is it the jack robot
yeah
he's actually really good carry because
it's really good like you can upgrade
him he's like it's not an add-on piece
to the game by the end of it by the end
of it he really feels like an actual
character not just some ID on you know
what I noticed
it was it was one cuts and I'm not gonna
really go into the cutscene because you
know no spoilers but it was one cutscene
where you know one of the characters
really felt for him and I said okay I
understand that he's not gonna be you
know like um like a MacGuffin or
something like that he's actually gonna
be a full-fledged character that's what
I got from it from the from the short
time that I played the full disclosure I
did not play it longing have enough time
to and when I tried to jump on xbox live
with me gosh and you know shout-out to
you guys out there that DDoS did cuz he
didn't want us to play you didn't want
us to have a good time but I just want
to say this part I like the fact that
Toby said you know he saw the scores he
saw what people are saying about it it's
not his cup of tea he's not gonna you
know jumping into it but all those
people they that's not about racers yeah
fighting games those those but when
those games do come out this is what
happens they bring a whole new
demographic in right and sitting inside
that game pass you go through it now you
finish the gays you maybe you don't want
to do multiplayer or whatever then you
start looking around on what's on that
list and you get to Kingdom Come
deliverance and then maybe that is in
your warehouse because Toby said he
didn't really like you know the gun plan
to cover shoot to cover shoot but in the
fake open world but now you into a real
open world and you really talking about
NPCs and stuff like that I just like to
bring that out there that even though
we're talking about gears and gears is
shining a bright light on the fact that
it was launched four days early and game
past ultimate yeah you understand
because other people get it later right
the real release all right at least next
week this week exactly so you guys are
hearing spoilers and y'all going crazy
and I'm glad that y'all feeling like
that because you can take that two
dollars and go to game castigate
yourself some gears I'm like I said I
want to say two car seats of commenting
ton shot the Samuel Prescott yes I
download the HD ultra Pat texture pack
on PC makes a huge difference it looks
so yes wait a second yeah how is that I
heard big clouds it looks fantastic now
I will say there is shout out to my boy
underachiever on arm on Twitter there is
some little we had a little issue with
their arm army inclusion and there's a
little sound issue that we have like a
little minor things I guess like no
there's a little patch they may come out
with what the game it looks phenomenal
on PC the point I'm trying to make
though is you gotta understand when I
went from destiny to PC right mm-hmm
the job is like it's not even the ex is
not even nowhere near where with the
very praising the Reno were the field of
view right because it's EP but what I'm
trying to say which is impressive about
Gears
I mean to me it's like if you got a 4k
TV in HD are you here you know say it
now if you got like a $3,000 rig with
the crazy you end up said then you're
here but it's still the disparity is not
that much sort of thing they're doing
that's what I really want to stay for
Xbox 1x owners you know I'm saying like
you're right there so that was not gonna
say and the other thing is just in
reference to UM
the importance of the title which is
just like this was big for in my opinion
this was big for gears to have this
level of quality and I'm saying yeah we
all know how this generation has been
for Microsoft as far as first quarter
exclusives and to have this level of
quality to see that how its received and
everyone enjoying and having a good time
and then it's a full-featured game you
got all these molds I didn't even try
that other mode yet what's the other
mode the resolution so you got the
campaign which seems to being
self-contained pretty amazing the
storytelling the character development
is just fantastic right now then you got
horde you got multi player you got that
solo mode that you got you're talking
about escape so to me the way I look at
is like this from this point on King
like this is the bar right from now on I
think they know they have to meet and if
you've been meeting man alright that's
to listen horizon for Met Ball and
exceed C and exceeded that bar see
there's a misnomer out there you know
guys we we gotta break that little
barrier we gotta take that false
narrative out and you know we gotta stop
comparing apples and oranges but I
understand exactly what you're saying
this is where you once every first party
title to be I need to be right but
they've they've been keeping this level
of consistency for what it is some
people choose to say a game isn't you
know that fun i sat there on sea of
thieves dancing for two hours in a
corner I had the time of my life and I'm
just saying that youyou can't quantum
you know fun well it's fun and people
are overlooking the fun factor in gay
I'm not now I'm not discounting it I'm
sorry everyone I think the argument can
be made for a lot of games right there's
games that we don't like that yo it the
fun factor is there and you're gonna
play it I just feel that it's such a
refined product as far as fully featured
as far as graphic fidelity yeah I just
saying that at this point I would like
to see future titles right and come to
the Miss Scarlet
halo that's what I feel like all I'm
saying is I think this is a good
foundation and a good way to build
momentum going into the next generation
this is this the type of title that I
know people who are on the fence with
Xbox not us right look there are people
that say no see a thieves in it for them
they're people that say state of decay
ain't it so as some people say yo they
not for not saying that for is a bad
game but for us is not for them they
want that single player like the kind of
the Sony model right they want that
single player great cinematic experience
yeah and this is the type of game I seen
so many people who weren't on the thanks
with Xbox pick up this game I'm
literally I have another theory I don't
think it was D Dawson I literally think
people were like because let's be real
the review embargo went out on Tuesday
right mm-hmm so people start to see
those reviews start coming in hot and
heavy right
mostly majority all positive I'm Sam
then you besides that you know the joint
then you had ninja on Wednesday right
you know what please get my knees yeah
I'm from everybody that taught when I
told you guys guys I think only um
addict was with me when I said ninja is
going to play Garrus day one and going
to show to campaign and he's gonna play
every one of those first party titles
and that would be huge and it's it's
part of a whole big strategy that they
had set up that we're not privy to and
roam at we we lost the magic and that
that stuff was magic all the way down
like you knew they knew they had a hot
one you know when you got a hot game you
know when it's 4k 60 running no you see
the PC version of it looking ridiculous
and you know it's gonna drop in game
because you know what it's doing and I'm
pretty sure going and they know this
quality this quality like you was gonna
say you was going to say exactly what
you're saying right now this bar is set
and and I think they knew that all the
way through I just I just figured it out
well like when I saw it I said getting a
ninja in to play the game to get in that
different demographic that will look at
mixer and a different light now that
strategically set myself up like you
said they put in the Foundation's in we
a scene of the building blocks to a
greater pasture basically my point was
just that you know the reviewers got
released at one day Tuesday Wednesday he
goes live for a mixer you know and now
it's this momentum this whole thing and
everybody's like you know what I think
it was the other way around
well he might live on Tuesday and
embargoes in even so what point I'm
trying to make is let's be real the real
release date was next week right for
what I think would have been no more the
majority of people to common people
right I think this is my opinion I think
more people were in tune to get ultimate
and not wait and maybe they
miscalculated as far as the xbox
language because we don't know we know
there were issues right they
miscalculated on the sheer volume that
like this week was the release date the
way people were acting that's just my
theory I know what you guys do I believe
you that makes sense I mean that makes
sense I'm people when you're you're
giving ultimate up when they first
announced today it was the dollar and
then now it's two dollars and then you
know that you can do the little the
little shyster where you could just get
you know three years worth of regular
gold and then transfer that to game it
came past ultimate I think a lot of
people jumped on that as well
so I mean for me I think I gave I get
King those nice guys for sure because I
knew he they were gonna bring him off
for specific stuff but you know we
talked about it it really does make
sense that he would be the guy at the
forefront of every major release on his
dreams talking about game past talking
about how great that is and then playing
the game
what's funny makes sense is when they
just started that string cuz I watched
like five minutes of it he was like okay
guys it's two minutes till six I'm not
starting til six I'm not getting in
trouble already he waited so he
definitely definitely had a rule book he
had to follow but right I mean to me it
makes all the sense in the world and I
think even more because if you look at
it things like game path ultimate right
they combine it and these deals that to
get people in the front door even then
it's still for the person that's not
looking for it finding game pass on its
own is still it's still weird like did
the discoverability of it is still weird
mm-hmm somebody like ninja at the
forefront somebody who just watches
streams and things like that
repeated stuff like that is not seeking
stuff out like that just means you're
mentioning it it's gonna bring new eyes
to it they wouldn't have had before so
that's absolutely true
like I said it just excites me you know
like I said you see this level of
quality to go on the next generation and
I think if they keep this up I said you
was nervous wasn't you nervous it was
more so like it's you know I like you
know I'm one of time people that's like
if people hike something up yeah I tend
to be like now let me see for myself so
when something like meets and exceeds
I'm like yo my question to you is you
know because the the the ton of rhetoric
behind it before it even got there right
it to get you trepidation to a lot of
people I've seen a lot of people who do
some flip-floppy yeah I'm not gonna call
a lot of people out here with systems
and doing all this other funny but this
level of enthusiasm wasn't here at e3
right and now you know people is out
here wearing gears or shirts and buttons
and gain tattoos and you know walking
around with a horde makeup on
no I'm never gonna agree with the dudes
that was fear-mongering like the game is
in trouble it's whatever I still I still
think it was bad luck not to show it the
you know not to show campaign at the
press conference I still ain't [ __ ]
agree with that let me ask you a
question
if you know that you pay the we didn't
notice let's just say they knew that
they paid ninja 50 million a new day was
gonna have him play that whole plan was
for him to play this campaign to show
the campaign then why show it on the
screen we wasted 15 to please anybody
you know when you just when you have
like you know WWE wrestlers like
sequestered under the stage flame like
monkey way like it's not the best way to
show your game or but just wasn't and
you know again a little bit of different
campaign stuff like the trailer that
they showed was just Kate you know
bugging out going crazy didn't show much
of anything
I still think you you know at a at a at
an e3 you really need to give people get
people excited about what the core arc
of the franchise is and with all the
multi players will last after the
single-player is long you know finished
I think single players withdraws people
write less competitive gamer and it's
and and with gears it's surprisingly
gears you care about these characters
right these get you think these are big
you know conquering new grows or
whatever but these characters are you
know you kind of care for them after you
know a couple of games in which you may
not expect out of a game that's about
you know change song people in half
[Laughter]
that's all I got pretty much on it man I
just it's just tremendous I just wanted
to make that point about it and our
attic I'll let you finish your topic you
know with it you know overall now that
you finished the game you know where you
have I have to say this is probably one
of the best games Microsoft's ever made
mmm well I think that if anything this
shows that Coalition is right where they
need to be in the person
is who it needs to be mm-hmm because you
know sure the open world thing it's like
I was telling the Lord you know it needs
a little bit of improvements but I think
the main reason they didn't want to go
straight down that path from the start
is because going from gears forward to
like an open world would have been a
traumatic change that they wanted like
put the right foot in the lake and blow
okay like a they go I think are they
gonna attack us for this let me let me
see if they want to even go down this
road before I jump in I think you know
side-missions would have been more
encouraged like you know do those I like
what they cuz what I liked about the
side bridges they had it didn't the
forest right it felt like stuff that
would naturally happen in that kind of
environment but I felt like you know
maybe do a little bit more branching out
on it but you know for what I got I
enjoyed I enjoyed every second of it
this is one of the very few games that I
would say it it's it's a reason to buy
an xbox that's what's up man that's a
tremendous man so we are going to move
on we got a couple more topics she's
gonna get a flight through but lesson
else before we move on yeah it's off I'm
gonna go ahead and thank Sir Toby and
warhorse to do for this a royal addition
at the Casey I'll come and throw down
listen everybody get your fingers ready
she's ready also Toby like so this code
is redeemable for any version of the of
the Royal steam at steam basis of Casey
be neat Royal Edition so thank you once
again warhorse videos a sir Toby and
here we go Oh
get to it boom copy/paste kill I wanna
know who's getting these you know you
gotta say y'all got it oh wow shout out
to my arm at Diallo 14 on super chat
just finished gears five brilliant game
great show thank you so much Molly we
might be on to something more corny like
after this part we we got we gotta get
you through this story cuz I want to see
your choice at the end
listen I've got stuff I didn't think
Horde would be that addicting I was
gonna play it like for a - we used the
player before bro it's so much different
now though I know I know it's so much
different now you know you know what
they could do - you could kick someone
it's funny they got some dish you know
what someone's on the ground doing the
crawl when you get them in a state
instead of the execution you can
literally boot them in the behind was
playing it some ways playing escape I
would literally just hit someone over
and over until they fell yes and I
actually couldn't text you long you're
gonna get down to few execute people so
wow you got I was having so much fun
anyway movie oh we got a lot of [ __ ]
good all of it yes all big announcement
this is about topic real quick on X
cloud man could be getting a bigger
presence in Korea so project X cloud
partners excuse me SK SK tell Co telecom
and Microsoft announced plans for a
joint 5g based cloud gaming partnership
so they held a press conference we saw
Phil out there in South Korea you know
SK Telecom would be an exclusive
operating partner for Microsoft clouds
gaming service in Korea the two
companies will cooperate to start a
public preview for Project X cloud in
October so they kind of let the cat out
of the bag it's definitely October so
the companies expect to take customers
mobile gaming experience to the next
level by combining SK Telecom's 5g
competitiveness and Microsoft strength
in cloud and gaming so this went down
this week there's a lot of good
information out so in conjunction with
it but I want to bring this to the Lord
I start with Noah told me first but all
you know I know
like I said streaming is big right now
and as far as starting the game will
mention momentum and things like that
you know what do you feel when you hear
about these partnerships with ISPs to
try to deliver 5g level streaming for a
project X cloud I think cloud gaming is
probably the future now that's that's
where most most money is spent as far as
I can see we have the you play plus
starting this month for free as well
the Ubisoft lounge their system as well
so you have only the game pass but also
get the use of then nothing if the game
pass already of course and there's
probably more coming so far sony sony
will have something well they have it
already playstation now but it was never
really well working right it could was
more of no it was more like a yeah it
was a streaming service thing but you
always had this many second delay thing
which made many new member so it was
error theoretically but not popular so
yeah we have to see how how things
change but there's more ian i don't have
only the the streaming services but you
have also in general new shops like
let's remember the epic store ride and
however epic store which is I cannot 100
100% understand the reason what behind
that why everyone is bashing it because
of course if the if it's about some
settings and privacy issues then of
course but in general I mean for the
developers is better for the gamer
gamers probably it will be better as
well mmm-hmm to have a bigger market
with more competition that's always a
good thing so I'm just repeating what
probably everyone knows but but Steam
for example has the 70/30 cut which is
if there's a whole lot babe you for for
a platform right or yes they have an
amazing system theoretically it's only
amazing because it's established right
even it looks the same for the last 10
years the only thing they they updated
recently were one two three years ago
was the the chat system and still it
updated it in the up the the least
necessary system was updated by their
yeah
things are changing but and I would go
even further let's talk $50 price tag
for a video game right if you said that
The Witcher for example cost at Witcher
3 was I think 40 million dollars and
another 40 million dollars marketing you
have now the gears was probably very
expensive reddit Redemption GTA is super
expensive games but one there $50 price
tag so that's well I probably I guess
change in the next five to ten years or
so so basically what you infer implied
is that based on the high the regular
high rise cost of bit of gaming but that
stagnant price point not changing how
difficult it is kind of to maintain its
kind of is that what you're going with
this
yes and that's why those streaming or
this this how this these systems like
services is yeah yes that they will be
more and more popular and will yeah I
don't know because Microsoft has those
games because they are all Microsoft
games of course so there will be some
money transferred back and forth but I
don't know how it is for like for us for
example for any other studio that has a
new game and wants to join one of those
systems how this looks like I don't know
so if you if you really the game you you
what you want is the first week is
probably is this the most important week
for you what you said it's like in the
movies yeah first we had a long and then
it will go down you don't have this when
you when you own this subscription
system boy good boy good boy no I'm not
sure again exactly how this will work
out but I think the sub subscription
systems yeah yeah will code for Kotik
kind of facilitate it'll make it far as
revenue is concerned yes all right
sounds good Lord saw I want to get him
in real quick um yeah man it's SK
Telecom you know South Korea partnership
is be partnership with Microsoft where
with this man is this big implications
do P is it are we making too big of this
where we at I mean I think it's big
because Microsoft understands that they
don't have a foothold in the in the
Asian market when it comes to console
sales they don't so you're not you're
not gonna have the same options you got
true Exploud yes very true you're not
going to one thing we have a Japanese we
have a Japanese publisher called yeah
and they're releasing Kingdom Come
deliverance in Japan and they decided to
go PlayStation and PC only see that's
exactly exactly I mean it's just they
don't have that foothold in those
markets right so for them to be able to
push X cloud in a way that's viable and
it's gonna be as widespread as they want
it to be they have to attack those
markets from from where those those
players play right those users and
they're gonna be on their mobile phones
and they're gonna be and they're the
ones that are at the forefront of you
know it's five you know 4G LTE five 5g
all this stuff so they have to create
those partnerships there because that's
the only way X cloud is gonna truly
thrive there unlike in the United States
for somebody who doesn't want to invest
in 5g all of a sudden but they do own an
Xbox console their console becomes a
server and they can stream all the
ex-college stuff from their console and
not worry about 5g if that's not
something you wanna investing in these
countries that's not as viable so they'd
have way have to so this is huge this is
huge we may think it's all you know that
it's forget the foothold in that this is
something they had you know they would
be doing anyway yeah but to operate with
the biggest telecom operator in the
country is huge and I think this is what
they have to do in all the markets in
which the Xbox console is not successful
the points there man Lord man you got a
chance to touch little X cloud at a an
e3 this year like where you at with this
announcement is this is this anything on
your radar as far as growth or you just
want to wait and see well yeah this
addict
addicts and butchers
let's get a lord King where you at with
a Phil Spencer man wheeling and dealing
will
we're gonna actually give him his name
though stop calling him Phil Spencer his
given name give him his entitled name
it's Phil dominus Maximus Spencer all
right now you see where he's weak at
what he did what does a real general do
where you are weak at you go and make
that your strength oh you guys laughed
at him when he was going over to these
Asian markets and working and putting
down the foot hole and he's standing
there he's shaking hands and he's
kissing babies he's going exactly what
he's supposed to do while he's over
there he's fostering these relationships
he has to be at the forefront listen
when scarlet releases it has to be at
the cutting edge so why not would you be
at the cutting edge of 5g why not be the
premier game console shooting that 5g
all over the place in that market that
you're a weekend to make it your
strength why not make the hottest newest
tech you get the best tech and you're
part of that mmm why not make Xbox
synonymous with 5g in a gaming community
that they are weakened like they said
you know you pick up your phone so we
just told you that you know the Japanese
a company that their partner would is
gonna do Kingdom Come deliverance in
another market where Microsoft is
weakened and they're not doing a
Microsoft version so who loses out there
let's say the two three guys is over
there they're one a Microsoft version in
every village the populace will go with
what the populace likes yes so if the
populace is love and PlayStation fine
right there I'm you you you can't not
sell bananas to people that want apples
you understand is you just can't do it
so what you have to do is make them love
those bananas you got to make
so that they are palatable so what Phil
is out there is he's making sure he's
handing out these Microsoft bananas to
everybody you were gonna have to get
these and you're gonna have to get down
with this show listen it is a generals
obligation to look forward to see where
he is weak and make that his strength
everybody said to leave those Asian
markets alone and I said no you do not
abandon that's me that's the sign of
weakness you are reasoning your weak
spot you make that weak spot your
strength and you maintain your base over
here you got a good product all right
would you just how crusty that is to
enter a market where you have an
established partners think of ubirr for
example all the elements services
whatever so what they what they do when
they enter a market that already has
something is that they're cutting their
own prices well what pretty much is
doing pretty almost every startup so
they're losing money for a very long
time before they try they're trying to
get market strength with out pricing
when he established one so for Microsoft
to become big and important in in the
Asian market this mmm this means a lot
of investment I mean being burnt before
they can equal or be on the same level
with Sony or whatever but it's a little
different no Toby in a sense that
because they're kind of the first with
the 5ge aspect with the streaming aspect
yeah I'm with you on the console aspect
bonus stream and it seems a little bit
different because then partnering with a
telco where generally consoles you know
are not really not really prominent as
much there to me seems like a different
strategy with the with the services and
5g streaming to try to get that with a
major partner I guess for us it's in the
States so maybe the equivalent of like a
horizon and I'm saying so if someone is
partnering with Verizon to say okay this
is how you're gonna get streaming and we
don't know if it's an exclusive
partnership we still don't know the
details of it but it seems to be like a
kind of approach but you know with the
streaming thing this is like kind of a
new territory from the outside yeah
that's what I wanted to get you is that
they have come up with services other
than yes what they have before if you if
you if you want to sell those bananas to
the air poor guys you explain them why
Nana is as good as the epic or even and
the explaining part needs a lot of
talking handshaking baby kissing oh you
wicked Toby Bob the big baby now listen
he understands that that aspect of it
has to grow you know like you said you
gotta burn a lot of money there first
before you actually bear fruit they went
they puts offices and everybody said why
are you doing that why are you doing
this when the X cloud comes in because
we got a chance to touch it and I'm
telling you I know y'all say it's
hyperbole oh listen I'm I'm more right
than I'm wrong guys and I want y'all to
go back y'all can go back to every
episode and write it down listen that X
cloud they're trying to get it to
everyone's hands that those Asian
markets they're running around with
their cell phones yes okay and it's in
their hands 95% of the time yes they're
not buying console row so if you can
stream it here mm-hmm
this is where you win yeah and it's
funny let me let me jump in man cuz I
got excited all this tech geek stuff you
know I love this to love it so I gotta
how it go King on world domination is
back service look man I think jokes
aside I think it's a fantastic move
fantastic I mean it give us some insight
as far as like how their positioning X
cloud that's number one and then King
your honor it like with the whole with
up with this with this right that's me
real first of all South Korea is like
the fourth largest mobile market gaming
market forget mobile just gaming market
in the world and this is predominantly
what they use they're not using consoles
so if you partner
with the number-one guys Telecom over
the number one ISP and you're partnering
to bring your service right my project
at cloud in the public trials right this
is stadia is not even doing that right
so this is a huge untapped market in
streaming that you're looking to list
and penetrate with to me that's a Power
Move
that's a polymer and to me it also
signifies the possibility of them as far
as like doing a mirroring similar
situations in United States because
let's be real that another another
problem that stadia is gonna have right
in a lot of forget stadia everyone who a
lot of people are against streaming say
data caps right but if you're partnering
with the ISP you just believe they're
going to link that system to alleviate
that they're going to make concessions
they're gonna have whatever is the
Netflix package or whatever it may be
mmm-hmm to accommodate that so this is a
bigger picture plan and you best believe
again who knows they may make deals like
hey SK if you with SK Telecom you get
this special rate with it what cloud or
you let prize amount stuff like that
there's huge advantages to partnership
and this could be a way of them hinting
alluding to how they're gonna get past
the data cap issue because again stadia
is not even doing this so huge deal
you don't listen we tested it and we
said it at nauseam you're not I mean you
like I said the Lord's were at e3 we
played XCOM in our hand I mean X cloud
in our hands with a controller basically
phone setup kind of like this and we
were at a data center 400 miles away and
it was almost like hardwired like it was
literally I could not tell the
difference good I mean and now don't
know what yeah idea idea
clear environment
I'll deal circumstances you are correct
low tone all I'm saying is as a person
who's very skeptical right it made me a
believer that it could be done right now
this is without 5g now if we're talking
5g
again as assuming market penetration it
starts to catch fire that's a big deal
as far as latency but you got five
running around you know say especially
let's just talk about Korea they're
gonna be on it that's going to be a
seamless experience and them getting
microsoft titles that they would
normally get cuz they don't buy Xbox
consoles right mm-hmm you're talking
game Pass now incorporated in that
service right huh
this is a big deal keep your eyes open I
mean I can nd today I think this is real
this is one of those subtle moves
they're gonna have big ramifications
that's that's just where I'm at with it
but all right can you guys hear me now I
can hear you all right so I'm gonna go
ahead and give away this last code I
have a question for the chat what are
the first one I answered you will get
the code who are the two Spartans they
put in gears to Spartans who are the two
Spartans that they put in gears for this
cold what cold is that attic which Kody
stomach Ocasio they still royalty which
is a polygon in the Royal Edition like I
was gonna do that but then I was like
it's kind of like stay out of people my
and I know we got to question we got two
answers already it's the press our
junior I didn't want to ask a question
to the games that I'm giving out like
exiled you say okay you say all right so
any any correct answers did a check I
see an answers flying right so Sammy
Prescott looks like even in salute I
salute you guys kcd royal addition in
the building man check that out courtesy
of Toby Toby made sure that you guys was
showing up here made sure that he
facilitated this great packages to you
guys I'm telling you and I can't I can't
he is such a great guy
trust me he
100% prepared you look at his setup his
setup is beautiful
he came ready to rock I am today and and
that's how he is in person
yes well prepared ready to go 100% and I
understand that man he told you how he
motivates he moves the light bumping
into it I'm sure
spitting bars you go and hit me up on
Twitter yes Samy hit Lord addict on
Twitter his wallet oh wow tile he said
he'll I got his behind whipped in iron
harvest in his first match but it's fun
guys and we still got any more codes
left before we arm we got one more time
to get out of here
I'm addict no that was all okay soku
everybody take care that's what's up so
I'll give it to you quick wrap up cuz we
got to get out a little football yeah
football is in and the Lords have been
in bending the knee so um did you see
the direct what was your feelings
anything stand out for you there's a
because we know the two frauds ain't see
it then I said I watch it I mean it's
just crazy though the stuff that's
coming to the switch man this ain't like
you know obviously the Super Nintendo
stuff I'm with told ya ain't happy
I was playing Super Mario World and n
Zelda and uh with nf0 so I'm just I'm
happy that's there and I'm happy it's
real me too that shows nice I like that
[Music]
overwatch that leaks before then we're
getting more ports of older games we're
getting Zener break articles from the
week defense coming we have good stuff
of course we're not new Zelda coming man
stop all this talk about that's not even
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
that's super OPC game
okay continue what's funny is it seems
like this is released because I'm sure
are you playing one of one c8 on the
switch you works me Maddy look out thank
you looking out for it there Gabriel
data looking over addict the director I
think you said you liked it you have
kind of we thought it was positive
it was good there wasn't a whole lot on
there I think the only thing that
happened on there is they might have
sold me a little bit more Animal
Crossing but I thought wait for that
Lord Toby did you catch the director I
don't like that Japanese games are so
just for example for example I like the
last Fire Emblem that you yeah but the
moment I got I get so fed up from all
the tee times cool girls have to have
lunch with the students we only you know
where I'm bad amazing right but stop
talking to me about your first let me
fight I don't know after in the
beginning I tried to listen to all the
dialogues talk to everyone and now I
just don't care at all no matter what
you say ayo be like it nice though
like it was screw you clicking I start
just clicking a random option of firing
boom hoping I got the good result
it's just well yeah and lend you a cup
of tea ito that's why I watched the
direct and I was certain Japanese
probably great and I for instance the
animal crossing thing I know it has a
huge ass fellowship and a lot of people
love it and actually I almost played all
the Pokemon games as well but the moment
I had to pet my Pikachu and like that is
the trend okay Toby listen yeah shout
out the to pet his Pikachu crazy oh I
get it a lot of these franchise is a
huge like a lot of the Wii U stuff you
know that the Xenoblade one I mean is
your question I just wanna ask you a
question right we don't sit here and go
through the whole list in the old pc
game because they couldn't get the new
game which on your pc go play all right
this is no game show me where to play my
games are like a teepee
see green that's all just paint all of
this is for the majority announcements
weren't for me I'm not the biggest
animal crossing I know I think you
mentioned that's not really me either
you know the fatal vesicle being the
fatal furry thing was cool I thought was
cool for smash see a terrible garden or
that I wasn't there by the end of the
year I'm gonna be more switch games than
you two frogs
listen I'm playing the best one Oh
anyone I never claimed that you ever
gonna I'm gonna beat you at beating game
Final Fantasy 8 he's in the bushes
anyways actress Charles of Manor did
look fine I will say that and I got a
shout-out sweary man Deadly Premonition
to members query you're always making a
little wacky games d4 dreams and stuff
like that so it's cool you know I just
didn't feel Xenoblade was end of the
show worthy that's all I got to say Oh
was coming out this week nobody cares
about this cute yes the show with the
poll do our people with the overall
positive reception and solid Metacritic
scored by recover regarding gears 5 how
critical it was a success of gears 5 for
the overall Xbox game studio brand the
choices are a not impressed with Xbox
game studio until it's something other
than Halo gears it wasn't be critical
Xbox game studios prove that they can
deliver high quality content and with
momentum heading into next gen or C I
don't care until they fix gears online
that is the question those are the
choices please write the IO people when
it goes up Lord Toby an absolute
pleasure to have you in the room
warhorse was represented iron harvest
was represented kingdom come deliverance
was represented where can I find people
find you what do you have going on in
the realm sir well
easiest to find me and follow me on
Twitter it's pretty easy to find me
there it's at Toby so if you follow if
the people follow you guys and the
aeronaut podcast just follow me there
because you can find me easily yes other
than I don't use too much for media at
all but I'm at I'm at new events coming
up so I'm going this year in chrome here
in Moscow in Russia it was not like this
then in Poznan in Poland so I will I
will go to South Korea to the g-star
event where I will take a look if the 5
key thing is really ok and we'll let you
know let me know what that has SK
Telecom give them your business card and
then again told me an absolute pleasure
to have you in man to see to grow to see
the success man you know it's really
good to see and again I call you guys
the underdog story of the industry and
to see the decedent where you guys are
it's just we're truly proud to just try
their culture and continued success man
so keep up the good work you wear that
day one so thank you as well or staying
with us becoming friends when did we
meet the first time three years ago
three it's always nice seeing you know
the people that that you know do the
most work actually pay off the day off
the see those guys the good guys in a
community who work hard and like I said
I just I love the fact that it's such a
cult classic we got new projects coming
and like I said you always welcome back
in the room whenever and you know
schedules a lot I played I was playing
it like two weeks ago and I was
streaming it and Laura Cognito I can't
remove someone else but they were not
they just could not stop laughing
because I kept getting cured in this
tutorial
yeah the trading it was so funny
listening but yeah absolutely pleasure
so you already know man and of course
like I said make sure you guys hit that
like subscribe all that good stuff the
IOP audio will be up in all that great
stuff Lord attic where can I find people
find you you can find me on Twitter at
Lord adders I'll tell you what and you
can find me on my youtube channel gaming
editor I will have my gears review about
tomorrow
nice no doubt and he's gotta believe a
control review coming up soon as well so
we got that going on from the Lord of
reviews Lord saw good to have you back
in the round sir yes sir definitely got
find me on Lord's table
IOP + bx sovereign on PSN and xbox live
and a huge shout out to Lord Toby for
comin to Germany
I mean you are honestly man one of the
most gracious people I've ever met at
any of these events
aa you know being able to interview and
talk to you it is an absolute pleasure
because you guys welcomed us with open
arms you're there with us for like an
hour
breaking down these games and nobody
else does that nobody else does
thank you very much attention to me and
Rick yeah Andrew Rick Messer
absolutely well we got we got a shout
out max I still feel you I got the
greatest press kids like this that's
actually the weakest part part we have
we have our own room we have our own
branded schnapps which I cannot find
here
nice nice shops is something I have to
import next time to Boston yes you have
to English snaps laughing now but once
you drink it you you will have to prove
if you're a good drinker or not it has
50% oh oh listen I'm down for all I
should be I will not be in the room
won't drink the schnapps but I'll snap
it up right hand the flask of the Lord's
[Laughter]
absolute pleasure to have you in the
room talking that talk way could apply
people find you what you got going on
sir first and foremost I would like to
thank Toby for showing up it is so
refreshing trust me um when I when I got
introduced to him by Rick from War Horse
that um and he introduced us to Toby say
you know I can't do it interview right
now I have this thing and I'm setting
that right now but you could talk to you
know Toby and Toby was a little
apprehensive at first because he said
you know the language or whatever like
don't don't don't worry about it we got
you you know and sovereign and him win
and then the rapport back and forth was
amazing and at the same time the game is
being played Toby's like you don't go
over there don't do that you know and
and he's staying cognizant while he's
answering the questions the multitasking
from this man the energy from this man
is incredible
he brought full energy here and on our
early day he brought my energy up so I
thank you so much Toby for coming
through with the great energy and bring
the snaps next time I'm gonna snap sing
around yes so king of the statues will
be up next week Wednesday Thursday with
a new statue unboxing and a new statue
to be shown I told y'all at the end of
the last episode that is gonna be
somebody that is strong so that
be anybody but y'all gonna figure it out
when you got to me oh yeah but listen we
also have a combat talk with the king
coming up soon because you got Shawn
Porter versus Aerosmith jr. which will
be a fantastic thing like yesterday I'm
not great in MMA and I wish I really
could give you a fundamental basis of it
I could just tell you when I see a great
fighter and I see a great fighter and
kabhi and I'm telling you if you don't
know this talent y'all need to to him
into this talent but um listen little
Lords again without net to get all the
information on the show's future past
and present and also um the last word we
were law kognito and make sure you get
to these reviews with addict I mean he's
really hitting it out the park he's
really hitting his stride and this guy
does a lot of hard work and you need to
watch this stuff to know fantastic
shout out to the shroom Kingdom with the
$2 super shot great show guys enjoy your
football Thank You Man yeah the last
thing I'll say just like I make like
King Sam sure you're hitting up Lords of
gaming net for all those resources you
know I'm saying opinion pieces
walkthroughs gaming news we can have
review is coming up attics got one
coming up also I want to shout out to
Josh reading has a fantastic series it's
called the shadow key primer he's
breaking down all the races that's going
on in destiny prior to the release it's
fantastic reading please check that out
my boy Lord Hector he's got one up right
now Katherine full body ps4
he's got the review up fantastic he'd
get his opinions on that and Lord mods
y'all polish brother he's got a great
article right now just facts PlayStation
5 and of course the Scarlett what do we
know so far the differences and all that
stuff and then the last thing I want to
say is the stream team shout them out
they will be debuting a show y'all
stream team Lord PDL boogie old-school
style MJ's a boss
monday looks like it's gonna be tomorrow
9 p.m. it's gonna be on the ILP Channel
please stop show some some love they're
gonna be talking about the streaming
game was gonna unique approach and I
can't wait I gotta I gotta sneak in on
that one too man wait to see that
see what's going on
you support them they're gonna have a
little show up there it's gonna be on
the channel so you guys tune in right
here the ILP and like I said Carrie West
you already know that's up right now
last word something - woody bonta's
that's up right now very passionate
discussions everybody if you have
anything else going on please enjoy your
Sunday football is live and well and on
that note we are out thanks